well green valley ranch is gearing up
for a special celebration this weekend
it's their 20th anniversary and they are
celebrating in a big way here to fill us
in on all the festivities is executive
chef eric kiefer eric thank you so much
for being here girl thank you for
inviting me it's really great we're
getting the party started early for sure
because all the festivities kick off on
saturday let's talk about some of the
stuff you guys have going on at green
valley ranch so on saturday we do have
our drop bar opening up it will be it's
newly renovated awesome cocktail program
should be very unique and and awesome
for that area
also at 9pm we have our fireworks
display that's going on so there's going
to be a lot of stuff going on in all of
our outlets that's why we kind of
brought some of these uh nice sweet
treats to show you now and so you can
kind of get a head start of what's to
come yes this is getting me excited for
the weekend and you have a fun
demonstration here prepared for us so
what are we making what are we doing
yeah so uh in hank's uh fine steaks and
martinis we have our nutella creme
brulee
so as i kind of do this we could talk
about also
what we have in some of our other
outlets so uh to our
side right here we have in buracha we
have our uh our chocolate skull it's
filled with a bunch of nice little
different treats ice cream whipped cream
all their different candies and you
break it right i've done it before
yes you did break the the valentine's
day yes it's really fun it's always like
a surprise pinata inside of the skull
and then these other things are so
beautiful i love the gold plated what
are those so on the gold wait we got
fire going on there's always something
going on so in the uh the gold plating
here we have our um
our
uh breakable ornaments we have our
breakable little uh mr uh santa bear
claws you guys don't think we're all
angry we just want to break things all
the time
around the holiday season so the stress
relievers
exactly we kind of use that stress
reliever okay this is looking amazing
and it smells so good i don't think i've
ever heard of a nutella creme brulee
before yes well it's all the rich
flavors of your typical vanilla bean
creme brulee but what's better than
nutella to add as well so a little bit
sweet a little bit richer but everybody
loves it it's too dye yeah you're firing
things up over here and i'm a little
distracted by this cotton candy we have
to talk about what this is in front of
us well let's talk about that now while
the sugar kind of cools down a little
bit so this is going to be kind of our
version of the aviation cocktail but
it's made with belvedere vodka instead
of the typical gin
so what we'll do is uh it's belvedere
vodka creme de violet uh luxardo
maracino uh liqueur and then a little
bit of lemon juice that is so fun we're
about to wrap up here so i'll have you
finish up the cocktail and just real
quick let's tell people where they can
celebrate what you guys are doing how
they can be part of it so you can
celebrate in all of our awesome
restaurants hanks at bautiglia buracha
tides lucky penny cafe and don't forget
to visit us at the drop bar all on
saturday fireworks at 9 00 pm awesome
it's going to be such a fun party i'm
grabbing this drink because we are
celebrating early this is so much fun i
can't wait to come by i'm going to be
there to hang out and celebrate with you
guys
happy 20 years be sure to check out
green valley ranch this looks delicious
thank you see you there all right